a new gun might be coming to valerant
for the first time that could completely
Shake Up The Meta but does the game
really need
[Music]
it before we get into it I would like to
thank our friends over at Shopify for
sponsoring today's video here's Liz to
tell you all about it if you're looking
to start a business look no further than
Shopify it's a One-Stop shop for all
your Commerce needs they are with you
every step of the way like literally at
the beginning when you need to come up
with a name for your business Shopify
offers perspective business owners a
free business name generator tool so you
don't have to spend hours thinking about
what name customers will gravitate
towards Liz wants to open up a natural
skincare business plug that in and as
they say in New Jersey bada bing bada
boom with a myriad of options to choose
from you'll find the perfect name in no
time and it will cost you exactly $0 and
once you found found the right name let
Shopify help you the rest of the way by
signing up for their free trial you have
nothing to lose and a ton of new
customers to gain and where do you find
this free trial you ask don't worry we
got you check out the link in the
description shopify.com thecore orts and
start your free trial today now let's
get back to the video all right so late
last week a video was posted on Billy
Billy showcasing valerent new Valiant
hero skin line what the poster didn't
realize was that they accidentally
leaked a new sniper that might be coming
to the game and by the time they deleted
their post it had already been scattered
across social media no it's just about
this three SN wait a new sniper goes
hard what would it be though now of
course some people began questioning why
the outlaw was the only gun in English
on the screenshot and speculated that
perhaps it just hasn't been translated
for other languages because it's
allegedly still being tested I've also
seen some players suggesting that maybe
it'll be a shotgun with a scope but
since valerant has always lumped
together weapons of the the same class
in the buy menu I don't really think
this Theory checks out but if the rest
of this is true and valerant actually
getting a new gun then I'm sure a lot of
you are probably wondering why the game
needs another sniper since the outlaw
would sit between the Marshall and the
operator at 2400 credits it's likely
because of light Shields over the past
year and a half we've seen more and more
teams opting to buy light Shields even
when they have enough credits to buy
full Shields since vandals kill with one
shot to the Head a lot of teams tend to
do this even on buy rounds because if
they get headshot well they're going to
just die anyways and even if you get hit
140 from a phantom then the aim punch is
usually enough to help your enemy secure
the kill we did a deep dive on the
economic impact of light shields in an
episode of cracked last year after NRG
implemented this strategy in a
Challengers match against Ghost if you
want to learn everything about how
valerant Shields work then make sure to
check that video out but fnatic then
popularized the light armor meta
throughout this year man clearly it
worked pretty well for them they're just
not letting him get that room they're
not entertaining the idea Leo the one to
send him away again astics Dynasty
starts today fnatic used this strategy
all year and they had the most
successful season we've ever seen in
valerant history but now it seems like
Riot might have a problem with the now
popular light Shield meta if we're to
believe these leaks then perhaps they
want heavy Shields to feel just a bit
more useful and in order to do that the
outlaw would likely have to deal over
1225 damage to the body across most
ranges that way you're able to onot
players who have light Shields but the
operator still retains its value by
being able to One-Shot players who have
heavy Shields that being said many
members of the community believe that
valerent economy is already in a good
place and if anything maybe the Marshall
should be tweaked before we add another
sniper the game's in a really good spot
in my opinion where there's a lot of
variety and ways you can play the game
and what you want to use inside the game
you know all guns having a specific use
is kind of kind of a cool thing some
might be a little overtuned like I think
the Marshals are a little bit strong
right now but uh everything else has its
individual use and rounds on certain
maps and certain areas and like if you
play to those strengths you see you know
success with it we still don't know for
sure whether or not the outlaw will
actually be brought into the game but
this leak does seem to carry quite a bit
of weight within the community Mike from
Bor leak seems to think it's legit and
says if anything Riot is just using a
temporary image for the weapon but
regardless it certainly has many of us
thinking about what the future of
valerant may look like I think part of
the reason that I haven't got bored of
the game after watching and playing it
for over 3 and a half years is because
Riot loves to shake things up and
whether that's with new agents or making
changes to certain guns they just love
to keep things fresh I'm not saying that
I always agree with their decisions but
as someone who used to play League of
Legends I'm never surprised when I see
them intentionally try and shift The
Meta every few months I think the idea
of adding a new sniper to the game is
very interesting but if Riot actually
wants to do this then I hope that they
try and implement it soon but since the
new act just started yesterday I'm not
exactly getting my hopes up the VCT
starts up again early next year so I
think it would be nice to see how this
gun performs in ranked and maybe some
smaller events before then but I'm
interested in what you guys think do you
think valerant needs the outlaw let me
know down in the
comments check check check test test
test what do I think of the
outlaw the name of the outlaw um I think
the name is badass The Outlaw and yeah
it just looks it looks sick obviously it
might not look like that but I think the
like teaser image looks really cool